Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
eternals 2 marvel video they just announced that
the movie's actually in active development they're
actually making the movie i'll explain when it's
probably going to come out because we know what
all of marvel phase 5 and marvel phase 6 are going
to be for the most part you've probably seen the
clip going around because pat oswalt basically
just revealed the news probably wasn't supposed
to do that kevin feige probably preparing all the
marvel snipers to get him but if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos she-hulk is starting really soon i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes just like i do
for all the other marvel disney plus series this
is going to be a bunch of cameos daredevil wong
abomination just the beginning of it but recently
you all priced on your feeds patton oswalt
appeared on good morning america and revealed that
marvel has already started working on eternals too
apparently they've been working on it for a while
and even though all reports said that marvel is
going to be bringing back both harry styles star
fox and his pip the troll not just in eternals too
but in other marvel projects as well he said that
he's hoping that they bring him back in the future
like hoping to see the adventures of pip the troll
and star fox like of course they're gonna bring
those characters back this is the clip of him
talking about that so pat there is there's word
out there that you might be part speaking of the
metaverse part of the marvel universe i'm all with
harry styles oh well yeah there's uh harry styles
and i are in a little post-credit sequence in the
eternals uh we play um i play pit patrol he plays
star fox right um thanos's brother it's actually
al it's interesting in early issues of the comic
see star fox originally when he first appeared
come back come back to me come back to me they
have announced there's going to be an eternal
sequel chloe zhao is going to um direct it so
hopefully there will be more adventures of uh
star fox and pip this is a relatively new clip
so i did think it was kind of weird that the
good morning america people were talking
to him about being in eternals when that
happened so long ago like yes we all know
that he was in eternals as pip the troll
i think it's more surprising that he's walking
around now there haven't been any repercussions
from kevin feige and the marvel snipers we already
know what most of the plot of eternals 2 is going
to be they set up some very clear character arcs
for all the majors like the eternals themselves
star fox and pip the troll teasing all the other
groups of eternals that are out there on other
planets currently that they plan on freeing from
heirs from the judge and the other celestials
control and rescuing all the earth-based
eternals from the celestial's world forge
along with kit harington's dane whitman becoming
full-on black knight taking up the ebony blade
and more big marvel crossovers like the
blade crossover in the post-credits scene
i'll get into all that in a second too because we
know where some of those characters were going to
show up and like they were going to have kit
harington's black knight come back during moon
night so like there were already a lot of
crossovers planned in other marvel projects
marvel also has the midnight suns that it
sounds like they're working on too also a
lot of people are still asking how harry styles
star fox can be the brother of thanos in the mcu
given what they did with the eternal's backstory
in the mcu in that movie in the origins of all
their characters don't worry i'll explain that too
it is different from the comics but it's not quite
as complicated as it sounds thanos wasn't eternal
from the planet titan as part of star fox's group
like currently star fox is one of the other
only survivors of the planet titan and he was
the prime eternal of their group like the leader
of the eternals when the planet was destroyed
but just in terms of actual release date like
when are they actually going to drop eternals too
marvel just announced all their phase five most
of their marvel phase six schedules there was
some animated series that they left off of the
phase five and phase six schedules that we know
were happening but marvel phase five is book solid
pretty much like they're not going to fit any more
movies into that which just confirms that eternals
2 isn't going to happen at least until marvel face
6 and probably not till marvel phase 7 and i'll
explain why because we know what most of these
undated mystery movies are going to be and most
of them are already filled up we got armor wars
that we know is coming in phase six now yes they
are still making armor wars that's why they didn't
talk about it during the panel because there were
so many mystery days here they're just saving that
for later announcements they have the wonderman
series that they just announced there's a nikoi
series there's also a separate wakanda disney
plus series about a different thing then there's
a nova series that they're working on yes there
is a new nova project that they're working on
there's the deadpool 3 movie which ryan reynolds
actually just started training for right now
there's the shangshi 2 film with director daniel
cretton same guy that directed the first film they
also just confirmed that he's the person who's
going to be directing avengers 5 kang dynasty but
they will pick a different director for avengers 6
secret wars and the russo said that currently it's
not them like the russos aren't planning on coming
back at the moment but they'll probably come back
for another marvel film at some point there is
also that x-men film that's going to be on the
schedule here kevin feige said he didn't want to
wait that long before doing another x-men film
but they're just calling it the mutants right
now there's also spider-man 4 with tom holland
that we know that they're making and then there's
doctor strange 3 which they basically tease along
with the incursions in avengers kang dynasty
and secret wars at the end of doctor strange 2.
even though they were using that post-credits
scene with clea to set up a lot of different
movies it was also primarily just meant to be a
doctor strange 3 teaser and even though some of
those movies and disney plus series might get
pushed to marvel phase seven for the most part
that's enough to fill up all those mystery dates
so that's why eternals 2 probably isn't going to
come out until marvel phase 7 unless they bump one
of the other big projects it's also probably why
they didn't talk about it at comic-con now like we
know they're still making armor works they didn't
talk about that at comic-con like i said some of
the mystery dates they're probably just waiting
to announce till later like oh yeah by the way
we said we were making this movie this is when
it's coming out during one of these mystery dates
kevin feige said marvel usually works about five
years ahead so there's like a lot of projects
that they know that they're working on that they
just haven't announced yet but like we're probably
gonna see the new x-men reboot movie before we see
eternals 2. and it being so far out is probably
why kit harington for example signed on for the
jon snow game of thrones sequel which i just did
a video for so i'll post that in the links below
because yes it was confirmed hbo is developing
a game of thrones jon snow sequel kit harington
himself is the person who came up with the idea
and george r martin signed on for it apparently
he wants it this time and the reason why he
probably did that is probably because marvel
isn't planning on doing a black knight disney
plus series at the moment and if all of his
future appearances for the next couple years are
just going to be like cameos or smaller crossovers
then he has a lot of time on his hands enough time
to shoot a whole ass game of thrones sequel series
both his black knight and sersi are supposed to
be in avengers 5 king dynasty in avengers 6 secret
wars we already kind of knew about that but there
might be more of the eternals in secret wars in
the celestials for that matter just because the
movie is so big we even saw new celestials from
the current celestial host during thor love and
thunder so like you'll start seeing some of these
characters pop up all over the place like wong
is like the new colson of the mcu just showing
up in everybody's project now there was a lot of
really cool crossovers and stuff they were going
to set up in moon knight that they didn't wind up
doing because of big virus delays but originally
what was going to happen with the black knight
on that series is because he works at a museum
they were going to tie him to a lot of the lord
that they were explaining with egyptian history
during the series even though they didn't really
get too much into it during the eternals movie
like there wasn't that much of him during the
first eternals movie part of the idea for using
his character along with the eternals is because
they did that in the comics a long time ago like
he had a relationship with sersi's character
and they both joined the avengers for a while
but in the mcu he's a historian so he'd be reading
about all these different major events across
history particularly across european history and
that was going to be the way to link him to the
eternal's history in a lot of these different
areas around the world particularly around the
history of mcu camelot because like during the
movie she gives him a ring with his family's
crest which she probably got from the original
sir percy black knight who lived in camelot
merlin was a real character like camelot was
a real place king arthur was a real person
the sword excalibur was real thena even plays
with it on the domo like they literally have
it on their spaceship the reason why sprite
mistakenly thinks it's the ebony blade is because
merlin actually created the ebony blade in camelot
and gave it to the original sir percy black knight
so that's how his family gained the curse of the
ebony blade but because eternals 2 is so far off
i don't know if they're going to wait that long to
actually mint him as full on black knight with the
armor with the ebony blade it sounds like because
of the blade cameo scene in that post-credits
scene they were trying to set him up for a cameo
in the blade movie which is going to be happening
much sooner and then we're going to use that movie
to do more supernatural stuff and start setting
up more of the midnight suns because apparently
marvel studios just trademarked the name midnight
suns for a project but like i said because all
the mystery dates in marvel phase 6 are already
kind of full up it might be marvel phase 7 before
they actually do legit midnight suns we do have 18
episodes of that daredevil born again series so
i'm hoping that they work in a lot of the street
level the smaller stuff during that series i don't
know if black knight would be material for that or
they try to put him in a more supernatural
project you can let me know in the comments
which other movies and disney plus series do you
want to see them use black knight in if he's not
going to get his own disney plus series speaking
of game of thrones and new episodes the house of
the dragon prequel series to game of thrones is
going to be starting really soon it'll start right
after she-hulk starts i'll be doing videos for
all the she-hulk episodes for all the house of
the dragon episodes be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss any of that
obviously house of the dragon doesn't have
anything to do with the mcu it's just the
funny connection between kit harington's character
going after a character named sersi sounds very
familiar it is all the meta easter eggs and jokes
crossing past here because of what's happening
with the actors and the characters and a lot of
similar names popping up jon snow and rob stark
in a completely different story universe going
after a character named sersi there were a bunch
of other big trailer videos that i'm working on
a bunch of other big announcements so i'll try
to do videos for all those as fast as possible
everyone click here for my brand new avengers 5
kang dynasty in avengers 6 secret wars video and
clicking for my brand new ant-man 3 teaser video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!